l'interpellation de quatre personnes une
femme et un homme il hier a permis aux
enquêteurs de lever le mystère sur la
disparition de christopher 16 48 ans et
de sa fille célia 18 ans tous deux ont
été tués très certainement le jour même
de leur disparition le 30 novembre
dernier ce sont les aveux d'un homme de
48 ans qui ont conduit les gendarmes
dans une maison abandonnée à l'écart du
village de bélesta dans l'ariège le
corps du père a d'abord été retrouvé
dans un puisard puis celui de sa fille
sous des branchages
originaire de haute saône christophe
force à ce jardinier paysagiste s'était
installé à mirepoix récemment sa fille
avait rejoint le sud ouest après
l'obtention de son bac en juin dernier
parmi les quatre personnes interpellées
une femme de 57 ans infirmière libérale
ex maîtresse de christophe hors sas
pourrait avoir joué un rôle central dans
ce qui ressemble fort à une expédition
punitive pour quel mobile dette ou
vengeance sentimentale difficile à dire
christophe forçage aurait été battu à
mort sa fille tuée par arme à feu
demain en fin de matinée le procureur de
la république de toulouse donnera une
conférence de presse
on en saura alors un peu plus sur les
circonstances de ce double meurtre est
le rôle de chacune des quatre personnes
interpellées